[Musik]
pro Woche
hallo
[Musik]
wie geht's Bruder
und
[Musik]
verloren wie die Mutter mit grossi
innerhalb von zwei Jahren
und nehme
installieren
[Musik]
mit der Stadt Polizei
Sozialarbeiter der Nachbarschaft oder
Rampe vom Checkpunkt geboren er Verein
mit dem Ruhm was sie autonom Käufer
wollte mit klarer regelschlussstrukturen
dann töte sowieso erste steht verlangte
eigens der Leon ist der Präsident vom
Verein mit seiner rund 25 Mitgliedern
die meisten von ihnen verbringen
regulässig zieht hier Garage
[Musik]
möchte ich losgegangen ist 92
ist seit 25 Jahren arbeitslos der
Sozialhilfe
das ist mir sehr leid tut dass ich hin
zu vernachlässigt habe dass sie nur Zeit
kommen ist die Welt für die scheiß
Drogen
Daniel zieht immer stirbt oder
dafür die schlimmste natürlich leiten
nachlesen kann also gute pur
gute Nacht
[Musik]
zu finden
vor fünf Jahren hat sich mein Freund
Geburtstag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
schlimm schlimm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Garage
hört ihr für die Lebensgeschichte
Punkt
vor acht Jahren zurück verletzt seitdem
so eine schöne Herbstmorgen
aber natürlich wenn Sonnenschein
Vitamine
vom Checkpunkt hätte Basler
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das wäre das Arbeitsangebot Kontakt in
Bern immer nur mit der Sozialarbeiter
ob sie die Fahrtkosten übernehmen weil
hier im Burgdorf gibt es auch ein
Angebot intakt so um auch
in den Schwung zu kommen mit
mitarbeiten wenn du ja weitergehen
möchtest mit dieser Ausbildung zur
Sozialarbeiter nimmt sich der einzelne
Mitglieder und deren Themen a und Coach
der Verein aus ganzes ist es Bindeglied
zwischen Checkpunkt und Behörden
Kontakt und Stadt Burgdorf gezwungen
das ist übrigens
mit junge Leute und der Treff an sich
und der Freiheit hätte ich natürlich
helfen Negativspirale
im Bahnhof trifft Rafael Danner zum
Passbüro vergleichtet wurde
früher
die 24-Jährige
[Musik]
ja
oh kleine
[Musik]
Afrika
James bumsand das heißt ja
am Zentrum
machen
und dort
im Sofien ganze Portemonnaie verloren
[Musik]
bist du
gestreifend Mensch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schon okay Mami
wie geht's
sprechen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
Checkpunkt
lustige miau ja
und
für drei Wochen bin ich dadurch
dankbar
ehrliche Fragestellungen
Kommentar überzeugt mich heute
Video beantwortet Geschichte
[Musik]
der neue Hund Versicherung